i fully understand that this is a
momentous decision
for a president and if the senate does
me the honor of confirming me
i pledge to discharge the
responsibilities of this job to the very
best of my ability
i love the united states and i love the
united states constitution
i am truly
[Applause]
i am truly humbled by the prospect of
serving on the supreme court
should i be confirmed i will be mindful
of who came before me
the flag of the united states is still
flying at half-staff
in memory of justice ruth bader ginsburg
to mark the end of a great american life
justice ginsburg began her career at a
time
when women were not welcome in the legal
profession but she not only
broke glass ceilings she smashed them
for that she has won the admiration of
women
across the country and indeed all over
the world
she was a woman of enormous talent and
consequence
and her life of public service serves as
an example to us all
particularly poignant to me was her long
and deep friendship with justice antonin
scalia my own mentor
justices scalia and ginsburg disagreed
fiercely in print without rancor in
person
their ability to maintain a warm and
rich
friendship despite their differences
even inspired an opera
these two great americans demonstrated
that
arguments even about matters of great
consequence
need not destroy affection
in both my personal and professional
relationships
i strive to meet that standard